what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and all things super i'm
your host warren thompson and we have a
lot to talk about today it looks like
jason statham could be joining the mcu
in fact if certain reports are true it
looks like he might have already been
cast as a character in the mcu at this
point in time the moon knight team over
at marvel studios has also commented on
whether or not steven slash mark slash
jake slash moon knight slash all of them
were blipped or not and what exactly
happened and to top it all off the
writer for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness talks about tom
cruise as iron man in multiverse of
madness something that everybody seemed
to really really want and something that
the trailers kind of actually led us to
believe would happen and as it turns out
this was actually a part of the original
plan for multiverse of madness so a lot
to talk about today we'll break it all
down and of course if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest marvel videos alright
so jason statham joining the mcu
something that i think a lot of people
would really really like of course if he
was chosen for the right character but
jason statham has done some amazing
films and it looks like there is a very
specific character that he could be
playing in the mcu that would make
perfect sense for him to play but more
on that in just a bit let's talk about
this initial report a lot of different
websites are right now talking about
this report but it originally comes from
giant
freakingrobot.com and it says exclusive
jason statham has joined marvel so
they're stating that he actually already
has joined the mcu and has signed a deal
with marvel here's what their initial
report says the marvel cinematic
universe will one day encompass every
actor working retired living or dead
marvel studios is currently in something
of a rebuilding period since avengers in
game in 2019 they have been steadily
replacing their original roster of
heroes with next generation versions and
adding in increasingly obscure
characters they then say according to
our trusted and proven source jason
statham is the latest star to join the
marvel cinematic universe and i should
point out that where it says trusted and
proven source that is a link to other
articles and other reports that they
have gotten correct in the past now if
this is true this is actually really
really huge but marvel has actually been
kind of doing this lately they have
gotten huge huge actors four phase four
and phase five projects in the mcu in
thor love and thunder alone the mcu is
about to introduce russell crowe as zeus
and christian bale as gore the
godbutcher two insanely huge actors also
in secret invasion that is coming out in
disney plus pretty soon they're getting
amelia clark to play a role and of
course you have to mention the eternals
the cast was incredible and we got
angelina jolie salma hayek richard
madden and so many more great characters
like jimmy chan in the mcu even though
gemma chan was already in the mcu and
captain marvel but we're just gonna
ignore that but this is something that
marvel is actively doing getting very
big actors and bringing them into the
mcu which is just awesome so who could
jason statham be playing he could be
playing a hero or he could actually be
playing a villain he also could be
playing somebody that doesn't have any
superpowers at all but he could be
somebody working for shield or i guess
sword now he could be somebody that
plays a major role in secret invasion or
he could straight up be a super hero now
jason statham is british and i would
love to actually see him play captain
britain now in the comics captain
britain isn't bald but that doesn't
necessarily mean that he has to have
hair on the mcu plus he does wear
something over his head anyways or he
could wear a wig but captain britain
would be a great role for jason statham
i think and it would be a really cool
character to introduce in the mcu right
now given his connection to the
multiverse captain britain is a part of
the multiversal team the captain britain
core our captain britain brian braddock
is actually responsible for defending
earth 616 which was just mentioned in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and captain britain gets his
powers from merlin the wizard himself in
the comics captain britain has
superhuman strength speed durability
reflexes all of those awesome things
that i think jason statham could do a
really good job at showing in
live-action form i mean essentially
we've seen him do that in almost every
movie that he's done but another
character that he could be playing which
seems a little bit more likely that is
speculated by giant freaking robot is
union jack and i actually think that
this would probably be a better suited
role for jason statham this character is
kind of like a cross between batman and
james bond he has no superpowers but he
is a british secret agent which would
fit jason statham perfectly now it is
worth noting that there was already a
union jack in captain america the first
avenger but it was a different version
of union jack it was james montgomery
flashworth the current version in the
comics is joseph chapman and this is who
statham would pretty much have to play
because the other one would be 90
something years old or probably dead i
think this character would work
specifically well with jason statham it
would be an excellent chance for marvel
to bring in jason statham's hand-to-hand
combat skills and make him a part of the
mcu but do you have somebody else in
mind that you would like him to play if
so let me know down below now as far as
moon night goes was moon knight snapped
or did he survive and if so what exactly
was he doing luckily the writing team
for moon knight has recently come out
and said what happened here's what they
said we definitely in the writer's room
we all collectively thought he survived
the blip that he wasn't blipped away
because i don't know how you i think if
he had been blipped and come back it
would be something that you would have
to address it's something you would have
to deal with especially as a character
who is trying to find his place in the
world and has a lot of questions about
his past to not touch on the blip of it
all felt weird so we kind of
collectively assumed that he was part of
the 50 that survived so mark survived
but was he moon knight at this time
according to the writers yes here's what
they said about that but as to what was
actually happening during that period i
mean i think that they say in the show
that steven basically woke up about two
years ago that was the first time that
they started living separate lives and
it was following the death of mark's
mother so that's been the last two years
and we assume the three years before
that was sort of mark just there was
probably in the same way that hawkeye
had his hands full as ronan because the
criminal underworld was running rampant
during the blip time i assume moon
knight was keeping very busy but it was
all being sort of done in the shadows
and he was sort of taking out a lot of
threats that never surfaced or saw the
light of day so mark actually survived
the blip and he was moon knight for the
past three years it looks like and
that's good to know because a lot of us
were wondering what exactly happened
with mark stephen during that time and
last but not least michael waldron the
writer of doctor strange the multiverse
of madness and also loki season 1 has
now come out and talked about tom cruise
as iron man something we all wanted but
unfortunately did not get in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness but
as it turns out that is actually what
michael waldron wanted as well now for a
while some outlets were stating that tom
cruise would be appearing in multiverse
of madness as superior iron man then
some of these outlets kind of changed
their mind and said well he was going to
but they cut that however michael
waldron debunks these rumors when asked
if tom cruise was ever going to actually
play iron man he replied with yeah that
was totally made up i mean there's no
cut footage of tom cruise but he goes on
to state that he did want tom cruise to
appear in the movie he says but i love
tom cruise and i said to marvel studios
president kevin feige at one point i was
like could we get tom cruise's iron man
i remember reading about that in anik
cool news back in the day that tom
cruise was going to be iron man then in
the interview rolling stone asked him so
to be totally clear did anyone reach out
to tom cruise in which michael waldron
replied i don't believe so i just don't
think it was ever an option because of
availability looks like tom cruise
probably wasn't available to play
superior iron man at the time which is
unfortunate because it looks like if he
was we probably would have gotten him in
the movie and i personally would have
loved to have seen that and i kind of
thought it was going to happen because
of the ultron bots but the good news is
we are still in an mcu where the
multiverse is now a very big thing so
the possibility of tom cruise showing up
as superior iron man is still very much
on the table and could totally happen so
let me know what you think about all of
this marvel news be sure to let me know
all your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel news and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof